What we've shown already is that if I know a single one of these angles
and one of the sides as well, I can learn everything there is to know.
I can learn the other angle by using the fact that they must add up to 180 degrees.
I can find the other sides by using these Trigonometric Ratios. Great!
But there's one thing we can't do quite yet, and that's to go from sides back to angles.
So, let's say I gave you a right triangle
and I told you this side was 231 meters and this side was 266 meters.
All right, let's say now you want to know something about one of the angles.
This angle for example. Now, initially this seems a bit tricky and it is.
Well, what we can do is even though I don't know what this angle is yet,
maybe i know something about this angle.
For this angle, would it be easier for me to calculate the sine, the cosine,
or the tangent of this angle?
Check up here which should be easiest. Tangent, sine, or cosine?